adelanto de elecciones renuncia de Dina
boluarte esas siguen siendo las
exigencias de los manifestantes que este
jueves han vuelto a recorrer las calles
de las principales ciudades de Perú
[Música]
renuncia de una vez y si estoy acá es
porque estoy haciendo por una lucha
justa por qué estoy luchando por el
futuro de acá de mi pequeñita de mi hija
Y ahorita la ahorita lo único que yo
pediría que que renuncie para que todo
se calme en juliaca al sur del país una
vigilia recordó a las 18 personas que a
su mes perdieron la vida en violentas
protestas cuando los manifestantes que
intentaban tomar el aeropuerto local
Fueron repelidos por la policía
la comisión internacional de Derechos
Humanos tiene conocimiento de todo esto
y ellos tienen que dar un
pronunciamiento a la población
cerca de 60 personas han perdido la vida
desde que comenzaron las protestas el
miércoles la respuesta de la Comisión
Interamericana de Derechos Humanos ha
sido otorgar medidas cautelares a la
fiscal que ha llevado a cabo las
investigaciones contra el destituido
presidente Pedro Castillo Patricia
Benavides Por considerar que corre
peligro en medio de la crisis
institucional en Lima la policía
desplegó Diez mil efectivos para hacer
frente a la convocatoria de protestas
por parte de la central Obrera más
grande del país mientras un grupo de
eurodiputados de izquierda pedía la
Unión Europea sumarse a los esfuerzos
por restituir la paz en Perú queremos
que es necesario que la comunidad
internacional tome carta en el asunto no
mire para otro lado ante una un
atropello como el que está sufriendo el
pueblo el pueblo peruano la perspectiva
de una salida institucional luce
bloqueada al igual que la convocatoria a
un nuevo debate parlamentario sobre el
adelanto de elecciones